[Applause]
[Music]
go get em Nathan Nathan Nathan do you
want bug pancakes yeah hey guys it's
been a little while since I've done a
video long and it's a beautiful Saturday
morning my wife's upstairs sleeping in a
little bit with the newborn baby Jakob
so I let her get some rest and we're
gonna make some hardcore dad pancakes
meanwhile my boys are running around in
various states stages of dress and
having a ball here with Grandpa I don't
have to go to work buddy
we'll make pancakes
we got the Aunt Jemima pancake mix here
and forget Beyonce man and Jemima is
worth it oh yeah she's a fine lady
active Emma
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there we go
that one
for somebody
[Music]
superdad skills activate
[Applause]
[Music]
it's done it's fun pancake time okay who
wants desert centipedes raise your hands
mommy I'll give mommy the prettiest most
sausage eat desert centipede and who
wants a sausage ladybug and who wants a
normal life hey everyone it's coyote
Nichols here and we are gonna be eating
the deadly desert centipede all right
guys ready okay all right guys
stay hungry stay wild no don't worry
about it
well guys here's baby Jacob he's three
weeks old today
oh yes and he's plumping up nicely he
was born like seven pounds six ounces
and he's already eight pounds 12 ounces
fattening up very nice well I've had a
lot of people ask me how Becca's doing
and she's Stewart okay we're making
really slow progress is that fair to say
hey the trusty Walker but she's getting
stronger and stronger and she even went
up a set of stairs by herself yesterday
so
not gonna make it a habit yeah the
spotter
bench-pressing but anyway thanks for
everyone for asking the families doing
really well all all five of us and we
appreciate you guys's support and
everything so stay tuned guys we have
plenty of videos comin got some exciting
stuff in the works I think the real boy
[Music]
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor voice
youtube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we've put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video